foreign
[Music]
well things are now through for Maddie
Ziegler and Eddie Benjamin because the
two have called it quits
we were best friends for a really long
time before we dated so it's like I'm
just hanging out with my best friend
every day people confirms that the dance
mom Alum and the singer have amicably
split after three years together E.T has
reached out to their reps for comment I
feel very excited every day that I get
to date him we have such a good time
together and Maddie and Eddie were first
Linked In 2019 and went public with
their relationship the following year
it seems like you found your guy I think
so
I'm like so nervous right now
[Music]
in 2021 Maddie starred in the music
video for his song speechless I think
um it's so cool that we push each other
every day he's also like completely
diving into this world and I've been in
it for a second so it's cool that we can
like give each other advice
um and yeah he's just been so supportive
and I I'm I'm just like his biggest fan
I can't wait for people to hear his
music because it's just like absolutely
insane and the support for each other's
careers went both ways it is the best
case scenario I'm so grateful to I
always was like oh I'll never date
someone that's in the industry just
because I don't know it's intense but we
very much are we inspired you well he
definitely inspires me every day
um and he says that about me which I'm
like hopefully the two weren't shy about
documenting their romance online either
even posting together as recently as
last month Maddie sharing this pick
alongside a couple in love Emoji
suggesting the decision to break up
happened pretty recently
foreign